well there is of course a significant
police presence in the city center there
as there always would be an armed
response as well who have attended this
incident we can confirm now through
Greater Manchester Police that five
people have been stabbed and taken to
hospital police say they're keeping an
open mind about the potential motivation
but they have confirmed to us now that
the Northwest counterterrorism command
unit based in Manchester is leading this
investigation while they try to
determine the circumstances of what
exactly happened here what the potential
motivation is we know that there is a
man in his 40s who has been arrested
detained at the scene there are pictures
circulating showing that man on the
ground with officers armed with taser
over that miners they effect an arrest
he has been taken into police custody
now it's very early on in this incident
so understandable that police are
approaching this through an abundance of
caution in terms of determining what the
actual motivation is they probably have
no real idea until they can get a
conversation a chart with this man and
we don't know whether this man will be
compliant with that whether he will say
anything to the police sometimes
individuals arrested in violent
incidents like this just don't speak so
it takes a while for the police to dig
into a background of an individual to be
able to determine what the potential
motivation was but this is clearly a
very serious incident that has unfolded
at the Arndale shopping center in
manchester city centre confirmation now
from Greater Manchester Police the five
people were stabbed in this multiple
stabbing attack they have been treated
at the scene i've been taken to hospital
we don't know at this stage just how
serious any of those injuries are again
it's early stages that will come in
dates from Greater Manchester police as
they gather more information but what
you'll see now is a very significant
emergency service response in the area
the the casualties those who have been
injured are being or have been dealt
with so now it's really about securing
the area trying to determine whether
there are any other individuals that the
police need to control whether there are
other suspects at large again they will
have in their minds what has happened in
recent months in recent years in this
country with terrorist attacks that have
involved vehicles and suspects with
knives and if you look back to the likes
of London Bridge there wasn't just one
suspect there were three terrorists
involved in that incident it took a
number of hours before police were fully
satisfied that all of those who were
involved in the attacks had been
accounted for it's likely that we will
see a protracted police operation around
the Arndale Centre with those police
reinforcements just checking the area
checking CCTV of course speaking to
eyewitnesses and making sure and
satisfying themselves that the one
individual they have in custody this man
in his 40s is the only suspect that they
need to be concerned about then he can
get into what the potential motivation
for the actual attack was but this our
Greater Manchester Police now confirming
to us that five people have been stabbed
in this incident and that the incident
is being coordinated and led by the
counterterrorism command for the
northwest which is based in Manchester
the motivation though they say still at
this stage remains unknown but they are
keeping an open mind